so my name is Eric Seidel and I'm here
today to talk to you about flutter
before we get into that since most of
you probably don't know me I should give
you a tiny bit of background about me I
have been a software engineer for coming
on 15 years now mostly worked on the web
on browsers worked on both Safari and
Chrome etc about three years ago I
helped found the flutter team which is
what I now manage and what we're gonna
be talking about today so flutter if you
haven't heard of us our goal is to make
it easier and faster for you to get to
Iowa's and Android in fact our team's
mission is to build the best way to
develop for mobile and you might have
stuff why don't we have lots of ways to
develop for mobile we do there are a few
rough edges and in fact we spend a lot
of time at the beginning of this project
talking to other teams who work on
mobile and understanding their concerns
and we heard a lot of the same things
and maybe some of these will resonate
with you
we heard that getting to mobile can be
slow and expensive
we heard that doing delightful things on
mobile which their designers want to do
they want to do their users want can be
hard and that the platform diversity
story of current mobile complicates this
and finally that if you really want to
reach all users at least in the US
market you have to develop for multiple
platforms and that can mean two or three
teams so we said to ourselves in doing
this there must be a better way the
development should be fast I mean here
it is we're in 2017 custom should be
easy you should be able to trust that
what you saw on your phone while
developing is what your users see and
finally that you should ideally be able
to build things once and take that hard
work to more than one place so let me
show you a taste of what we've built so
I'm gonna switch over I'm an Android and
an iOS phone I'm gonna switch over to
the iOS one here and so we can fire we
have this iOS phone and I'm just gonna
launch one of our little demo apps and
the first thing that you'll notice you
may be it went by too fast but of course
it just flies open Scrolls beautifully
hits every frame there's lots of pretty
little demos lots of the Lanham Asians
etc but I can also show you this same
app on Android buy switch over here's an
Android phone same story boots up
beautifully scrolls beautifully you
notice that this now looks more like
Android different scroll behavior
different title alignment different back
behavior etc so these just look like iOS
and Android apps and they aren't just
iOS and Android apps but one thing you
may not notice is that flutter is
painting every single pixel you see on
the screen handling every single touch
ending every single gesture and so I can
do crazy things like this so I'm on
Android here I go into our little debug
menu and I turn to iOS and so now when I
scroll I get different physics I get a
bounce behavior and when I go in so this
is for example an iOS style control and
I have a back gesture all because we
control every single pixel every single
gesture and we're gonna talk a lot more
about how we do that but that was a
taste so let's go back to our slides so
again our goals here we are in 2017 we
want to build something beautiful
something fast let's talk about how we
went about doing it so we thought about
these goals and what problems we were
gonna solve in the mobile space and we
found some alliteration maybe a
thesaurus and we came up with this list
of things we wanted to solve and I want
to talk about particularly because this
is a tech conference the tech that we
built to solve these problems so let's
start with fluid why do you care about
fluid we want to go the fluid developer
experience we want to keep you in flow
we want to get you home early this is
the thing that most personally excites
me about this project in part cuz I am a
software engineer and I like saving time
but I also like looking around my
colleagues and thinking about the hours
of their day that I help save
that I gave back to them because I have
plenty of things in my life that
distract me out of flow
I feel like fighting my toolchain should
not be one of them as so elegantly
expressed in this comic so let's talk
about the tech what do we build well
first big part is that at a very low
level our system we built in a
technology that we called hot reload
you've seen other text perhaps with a
similar name I believe ours is a bit
different let's talk a little bit about
what this does and why you care so hot
reload typical dev cycles is you spend
seconds or maybe minutes we talked to
teams inside Google who had tens of
minutes dev cycles waiting for Xcode to
turn etc and then you get plopped at the
first screen of your app and then you
scroll around and fiddle around inside
the screens and you find down in the
eighteenth screen your bug and then you
go and you blindly try and fix it and
then you repeat this cycle ha reload is
about staying at that eighteenth screen
or fourth screen on the slide and just
fixing it right there and so I can show
you this is our actual dev cycle our
actual time between code and device
inside flutter and you can see in this
gift I'm changing the color and hey
saving and it's immediately reflecting
on the device similarly I'm changing the
logic of my app and again immediately
reflects on the device this is very
powerful saves you a lot of time uh and
also I should say this is because we
built it so low-level into our system
and we built the rest of the system
around this is really works this is the
default way that you do development and
we test and we record stats from the
wild it's fast you know that it works
we know that people use it and in case
there's a lot of very interesting
technical details which we could spend
an hour talking about but here's a taste
and there are several youtubes on this
topic that you can watch and learn a ton
more about how this works how we make
that magic happen
so another thing that I should talk
about one of the lessons that I learned
in doing this is how much language and
toolchain matter if you're trying to
accelerate developers
and so we started out in one language
and actually built two full copies of
our system before switching this is
something I've never done before here we
were a year into our project we were
switching languages we started out
actually with JavaScript it didn't in
the end work for us and so we switched
and we went on an exhaustive search
tried lots of languages basically
anything we could bring to mobile and
ended up with one that I didn't really
expect but has turned out to work out
very well and that language you may
never have heard of because it's kind of
small
it's called Dart so this is a language
that's actually in heavy use inside
Google it's one of the accelerated
growth languages right now it's used to
build really big things multiple
millions of lines of code that drive
some core business for Google we didn't
really care about that except that we
knew that this meant that it was
battle-hardened it could scale and then
finally this team and this is a part
that I did care about cared a lot about
productivity and they had already seen
big productivity gains in the web
platform which is where they were
currently targeting and we worked with
this team to help bring this language to
mobile so we ended up really liking this
decision it took us a while to get there
but there's some really neat things that
this language does that I haven't
necessarily always seen elsewhere like
for example this one this language both
has a fast development cycle which
you've seen but also when it's time to
ship compile straight to arm code so you
just ship straight to the CPU straight
to the metal to your users I also has an
optional but strong typing system which
again those million line apps or
multiple million line apps leverage
heavily and we also leverage heavily it
has a tree-shaking compiler which helps
you to use a large code base but then
only produce a tiny binary out of it
only the parts that you use all right
has generational garbage collection
which basically means fast we do lots of
tiny tiny allocations and they're very
cheap to make very cheap to let go of
and finally we found it familiar easy to
learn if you use Java or JavaScript this
will feel totally natural to you final
thing that I learned through this
process was how important tools were and
I'm not going to
read off all this to you but we have
spent tons of time building tools if you
want to accelerate developers you have
to build and invest in tools and we have
done that so I want to show you what
this workflow actually looks like so I'm
gonna pop out of this into an editor so
footer supports a variety of editors I'm
just gonna use IntelliJ because that's
what I have a nav on this machine this
is a bit like a cooking show I already
followed the template and did a create
over this is about two minutes into the
process we just didn't have to wait for
Xcode to submit up for the first time
so here I've run this very first
template app I just have this little
counter again of course it works on iOS
or Android I happen to be using the iOS
simulator but you could use whichever
and I just want to show you again that
dev cycle so if we change this to red
right and I just save and boom if I go
and I say want to change this text right
because that button is actually a fab a
floating action button there again
appears right away same thing I could
add some text say things like hi strange
loop and there you go
in case this is the dev cycle this is
what you live in this is what you do
keeps you in flow all day long and we'll
show more of this in a bit let's go back
and talk a bit more so our second goal
the second thing that we wanted to solve
was that we wanted to produce a system
that was flexible so that developers
never had to say no to their designers
this is was in part due to direct
requests from these teams that we worked
with earlier and part to us just
watching the market and seeing what was
happening go on are the days of your
where you just produce a cookie cutter
checkboxes and buttons OEM widgets app
now much more common is for folks to do
very custom brand forward design and
these are just live apps pulled from the
iOS and Android stores and similar we
also learned through this is that even
teams which told
inside Google but no we're just gonna do
material design we're just gonna follow
the spec would still do custom things
perhaps without thinking about it and so
there's at least three things that are
violations of the material design spec
in this screenshot that we're very easy
for the team to create because they had
tools and matched what their designer
wanted so another thing that we learned
or how we went about doing this how we
created a flexible system was layers
lots and lots and lots of layers so this
again came from direct developer
feedback as we were starting this
project one of the developers put it
that they felt like dealing with some of
these systems was like they were dealing
with an iceberg that they had this tiny
little API surface that they were
allowed to use and they knew that there
were big powerful things buried under
the ocean they could see him but they
couldn't touch and so we wanted to build
a system that in a sense flipped the
iceberg and put all the good stuff up
under your control in the same language
that you're writing in so you can jump
to definition all the way down you can
edit it etc and so I'm gonna talk about
some of these layers that we built this
is an extremely simplified layering
diagram we have lots of layers but we're
gonna walk through it so starting at the
bottom this is our runtime api these
dart colon api's we built one called
dart UI this basically gives you a
canvas some accessibility hooks a way to
layout text some networking api's and
that's about it you can write it this
layer your typing a lot of code but you
certainly can if you want to on top of
that we have a rendering layer which
should be very familiar to someone who's
worked in UI programming before this is
a stateful view model very typical way
the job of this layer is to do caching
let you put a box on the screen while
you move it around to do layout to do
paintings do compositing that sort of
thing one of the drawbacks of working at
this layer and is typical for other view
systems is that there are some
complexities a common one is that this
sort of stateful view model has a create
update separation so you both when you
create the view you have to write a
second code path to up
the view and those can get out of sync
and that can cause all sorts of weird
bugs and so folks build layers on top of
this as you've seen for many years the
one that we chose to build was a widgets
layer and this widget layer basically
handles composition for us everything
that the rendering layer tends to have a
widget as well but widgets are how you
compose those how you assemble those
into new widgets that you can reuse it
cetera our widgets layer layer is very
react inspired these are immutable
widgets short-lived ephemeral objects
and they help solve some of these
limitations of working at the view layer
it's much shorter to compose at this
layer it also has a very simple data
flow you just always create new widgets
you don't have to worry about updating
them and then the final layer I should
talk about is the sort of layers of
opinion and we have several of these we
for example have some material design
which you saw already we have a set of
iOS widgets which your so saw a little
bit of called Cupertino and typically
when you use this framework you sort of
build your own opinionated layer so
let's go back down and talk about some
of the technical changes technical
innovations we made at these layers to
do this kind of flexibility to do the
kind of speed that we wanted so one is
rendering to understand rendering you
have to know a little bit about our
pipeline so flutter has a very strict
pipeline of how data flows to the system
starting to the vsync or user input and
ending out when we actually push pixels
to the to the GPU the part that I want
to talk about starts in this rendering
layer so rendering handles things like
layout again painting and compositing
and one of the things that we learn and
working in this is that simple can be
fast if you start with simple well
understood algorithms or algorithms with
well understood properties you can build
simple things and take advantage of
those properties to go fast so let's
talk about for example how we do layout
in painting it's typical in other
systems to some times join layout and
painting into a single paint phase or
it's typical in layout to have a
multipass layout where a single widget
or a single view will walk all of its
children to gather some information and
then we'll walk them all again to lay
them out this isn't
how things are done in flutter or we
have intentionally separated layout and
paint and do a single pass to reach we
walk all the way down through all nodes
and all the way back up and this allows
us to scale to much deeper trees and you
might be used to in other widget a
systems another way in which we found
simple is fast is that we found that
with very simple constraints you can
generate expressive layouts so basically
everything you've seen is done through a
very very simple constraint model I've
just basically min max width and height
this is in contrast to say how you like
it functions UIKit uses a much more
sophisticated or much more complicated
linear constraints model and that has a
general purpose constraint solver to
solve that and we found that we can do
something simple and very fast instead
another way that we did things
differently here is that typically how
you do repainting is that you collect
the dirty wrecks and then you repaint
based on based on that and we found that
in the modern mobile era it was simpler
and faster to invalidate sub trees
because modern GPUs are very good at
compositing and we could take advantage
of this to go fast this was actually a
big speed win for us I wanna talk a
little bit more about more innovations
this time at the widgets layer so one of
the actual things that we did
differently here I don't know of any
other react style system where both the
reactive layer and the view layer are
written by the same team and we got to
take advantage of this in building the
system but before we talk more about
widgets you should know again a little
bit of history so I said I worked on the
web for a better part of a decade when
we started flutter I was still sitting
with the chrome team at Google I was
still steeped in the web world and one
of the things that was going on in that
time was the extensible web manifesto
and if you've worked in the web you
might have run across this this was an
effort at the time and there were a
bunch of related documents to convince
standards organizations to focus on
explaining the web platform rather than
bolting on more features and this is
something that we really took to heart
in building our system
and maybe to the extreme and strongly
favored composition over inheritance let
me talk about what that means and what
that changed so a case study would be
padding so it is very typical in these
systems to have these sort of container
objects that have lots of little
properties that you set when you want to
build up so like you know dibs or this
way when when you want to build up a
complicated UI in our system we are pass
re art our container class if you look
at it it's this cascade of if statements
or if you've set one of these properties
we instead just wrap the subtree in
another little simple widget and I
perhaps crazy example of that I don't
know of any other system that has one of
these is we have this very very simple
padding widget and thus none of the rest
of the system except maybe container
have a padding property because they
don't need to you don't need these
cross-cutting concerns when you have
this composition sure you can build your
own widget and rap and padding but you
build other widgets commonly out of lots
of these little widgets and this
composition is all over the system so
here again in our animation system we
have the animation system is built of
lots and lots of little pieces that
again you can replace and you can add -
there's no locked box here there's no
like fancy animation system that would
be so amazing if you could just specify
your own curve of course you can specify
your own curves here
so in our an efficient ism you generally
start with an animation controller which
knows how to produce a stream of doubles
you then might connect it to a curve or
a series of curves that consume doubles
and produce another stream of doubles
and then again you can chain those two
tweens which know how to consume a
stream of doubles and produce a stream
of whatever Rex or colors etc a pattern
that we find strong enough so
flexibility let's talk flexibility I
want to just show you a live example
here very briefly if I switch back to my
iPhone I can just show you an in
production app that takes advantage of
this so this for example is an app built
with flutter shipped and doesn't really
quite look like iOS doesn't really quite
look like Android
but rather is their own different look
and feel and this is them taking
advantage of this flexibility to build
what they wanted to build so let's go
back and show you some of this
composition so if we continue down our
little tiny example that we started with
hi strange Lupin again we never lost
state we still have our number seven in
the in the corner we can build more
complicated things using this
composition so say for example I sent
this to my designer I'm ready to ship my
counter and my designer was like oh I
want a different floating action button
that is more styled in the way that we
do things I want an explosion or
something like that we can build of
course our own floating action button
there's no secret so of course we can
just jump to definition all the way down
and read the code but you'll find it's
very simple it's not very mean you can
just keep going jump jump jump jump all
the way cuz again all the code is
written up at your layer of the system
but we can also just make our own so we
can just make this my fab right don't
get a tooltip but we'll just implement
this
I'm gonna use my fancy editor to splat
out a widget I don't talk about exactly
these classes but there there are more
talks on YouTube that can explain all
this to you if you if you so desire
we're gonna type one out my fab actually
I wanted a state less widget my fab save
hot reload oops
boom we crashed a little app it's
telling us that we haven't actually
implemented a constructor for this we're
constructing am i famine we haven't
handles and we could have learned this
before we even how it reloaded because
we could have looked at our live
analysis that happens right as we type
because again I talked about the focus
on tooling before but we can just fix
that it's very easy we just do a my fab
this unpressed
this child we should I guess actually to
find those so we'll have a void callback
for on pressed and we'll do a final
widget for child right now we send the
sucker
oops we have another bug
what's it say aha it's because we made
them required arguments when it expects
us to have named arguments so we'll fix
that won't send it again and there we go
so I'm back I never lost state I went
all the way through that error I never
stepped out of flow but we're not
drawing anything and that's because if
we looked at our at our build method
we're just returning an empty container
so we could take this container at our
child that we're passed in and now again
milliseconds later we're drawing
something on screen we have our little
icon so now we could say wrap this again
I'm using my fancy editor in a new
widget because when we have we think of
this budding we want it to float right
so we're gonna have to the way you float
things in the material side of the world
is you make a material and we'll tell
this thing to reformat if I can remember
the keystrokes whoops
okay we'll we're gonna go ahead and add
an elevation to this elevation will make
it I don't know 12 sounds like a good
number and we'll give it a color cuz our
designer told us that they want fab to
be green so we'll do colors green and
we'll send the device and now we have
our little fab with the shadow and it's
green but we can keep going I just
reformatted so this is all easier to
read for one this fab doesn't yet handle
presses so the way that we do that in
the material world is we add an Inc well
which is something that knows how to
here I'll use my fancy editor again to
wrap in a new widget Inc well we have a
child and the inkwell also knows how to
handle our on press so we'll do our on
tap the passer on pressed I know this
feels a little magical because I have to
do this so quickly to fit into our time
but now we have you can see we've done
very very little typing we're up to all
of ten lines and we now a functioning
button and we can complete this by
giving our container the desired width
height
and I think you know we can send that
again immediately changes and we go back
to our material and we're gonna make
this a circle because I think that our
our designer didn't want a square button
right that's it we're done
in all of whatever that was two minutes
and ten lines of code we have built
we've rebuilt some core cost core
control that we can now customize to our
hearts content this is just how the
system works this is how composition
works in our system so let's go back to
the slides I hope you guys are as
excited as I am about working in systems
like this I like when the Machine does
what I tell it to so the final thing
that I want to talk about the final part
that we wanted to build was something
that was faithful something that you
could trust would deliver the designs
that you worked hard on implementing on
your phone to all the phones of your
users and so I want to talk about well I
guess we should start about why why you
care about this well again this came
from those early discussions we were
talking with all these teams and they
talked about things like that their apps
would break do the carrier-based theming
that they would have to fight with
platform and hardware differences that
would cause their apps to look weird
sometimes that they also had frustration
with waiting for their users to upgrade
they wanted to use some fancy new design
or something like that but they couldn't
push that until enough of their users is
upgraded so for example I actually have
kind of a counter example of on this
slide where you see this is a phone from
2012 two years before material design
ever existed that is running material
design via flutter and you could imagine
doing your designs and having that level
of control and pushing to all your users
now and so the insight the tech as to
how we got there
was to go to the metal this is something
we realized relatively early on that we
needed to build our own runtime but we
didn't want to invent reinvent the wheel
and so we
actually spend a lot of time on this
searching far and wide for systems that
had already been battle-hardened so we
took some graphics a part of the graphic
stack out of chrome we extracted a bunch
of text logic out of Android and of
course as we talked about before we took
a language that had been a successful on
the web and we brought it to mobile and
I should talk very briefly about some of
the changes that we made to these
systems because we didn't just take them
as they were but for example for skia
which is our 2d graphics library we only
use the GPU parts because again we're
working with 2017 right all these mobile
phones have pretty good GPUs in them we
also worked with this team to add color
correction so for example even when
you're shipping to really old phones you
can trust the ear and just look right
and similarly we worked on adding a text
library on top and OneNote sort of a
thing that fell out of having had built
our own runtime was that then we were
faced with all this portability and it
was kind of neat thankfully again so
much of the heavy lifting is done by
these component parts that we salvaged
from other products for example dart is
our cpu abstraction and has a lot of
different technology in order to behave
nicely on all these different
configurations and similarly skia which
implements a bunch of different backends
to do the same thing for our GPUs but
then our tests worked everywhere and our
product ended up working everywhere now
we're focused on iOS and Android today
we don't really talk about this but
flutter really goes all sorts of places
I've seen it run on watches I've seen it
run on set-top boxes I'm just kind of
waiting for somebody to send me a
YouTube of them running it on their
refrigerator because I'm sure it can be
made to work which is interesting and
maybe we'll do something with that in
the future but a final insight I talked
about how it was important to get your
designs intact to your users but it's
also important to match the expectations
of your users be faithful to their
expectations on the platforms that
they're running on and we spent a ton of
time on this we started by making our
pixels match and it was important that
our our buttons look
all right and we actually found that
users didn't really care about that when
we studied that we cared and it's stuff
we still to it but users what they cared
about was that the feel they cared about
that when they tapped the the targets
were big enough they cared about when
they moved and then when they scrolled
that it felt the same way that the rest
of their apps felt that the gestures
felt the same and so we spent a ton of
time on this about all sorts of
interesting tools to make sure that we
understood that say like this one is for
scrolling that we could tell you exactly
how many pixels our scroll velocity
differs from the OEM controls for
example okay so that's basically what I
wanted to tell you I hope that you
enjoyed learning about the different
problems that we're trying to solve the
tech that we use to go about solving
them I should talk very briefly before I
go I know this is a Tech Talk but we
could talk a little bit about product
which is that this is a very new product
we just released or announced to the
public our alpha in May of this year at
Google i/o and since then we've seen an
explosion of usage we're already up to
over a hundred apps you know with this
brand new thing push to play and we've
seen an ecosystem develop over 80
packages in the dart ecosystem that are
very specific to flutter and again as
you saw we've seen some big brands
already adopt us one was launched last
month
this was Hamilton featured on both
stores over a million installs and very
well reviewed finally I guess what I'm
really here for since this is again a
tech conference is that this is all open
source it's been open source since day
one I like working in that environment
but open source is all built on
community and we do have a strong and
growing community and I'm here to invite
you if this sort of stuff gets you out
of bed in the morning like it does me
you please should come check us out
again we have over a hundred and
twenty-five contributors who are main
and posit Ori and probably a lot more
than that if I counted up all the little
ones over a thousand people in our
dinner this is a very active project and
we
love to see you there so thank you very
much for your time